Speaker 1: All right, why don't we try Brenda from
Minnesota. Brenda, we've spoken before, right?
Speaker 2: Yes, yes, we have. What's going on?
I have been outed and as a boomer, by the way,
Speaker 1: a very good thank you.
Speaker 2: So I wanted to ask you
about there was an incident that
occurred a couple of days ago where a
BBC journalist was chased and hounded by anti
maskers and anti boxers. Yes, I saw that. This
is really concerning to me because I kind of feel
like these conspiracy theories can lead. I mean,
acceptance of a conspiracy, this can snowball
really fast is my concern. I think it's
people of this extreme are not a problem now. But
I think in the future it could it could snowball
really fast because there is so much distrust
of official news sources these days. And then
people have they just believe whatever they read.
Speaker 1: Brenda, I would go further. I think
it's a problem now. And the more I talk
to conspiracy experts, the more they say
it doesn't matter if their most prominent
wacky belief isn't that dangerous. It
never is an isolated belief. There's
always more behind it. There's either
racism or anti-Semitism or other conspiracies.
I think we can't take the approach of
these people could be a problem down the line if
they transfer their wacky beliefs to other areas.
I think we have to see them as a problem now.
Speaker 2: Well, so then what is the solution?
And I'm not familiar. Maybe I missed
an episode or something where you went
through proposed solutions, but no, no,
Speaker 1: no, there's been no episode
on the solutions. I don't have them.
Speaker 2: Unfortunately, we can't
just magic facts into people's brains
Speaker 1: know that, that we're still
searching for a solution. We have a problem. We're
searching for a solution. I hope we can find it
Speaker 2: that that would be
that would be an interesting
show that I would like to see. Yeah, well,
Speaker 1: I'm working on it. I will I will
broadcast that as soon as I discover it.
Speaker 2: OK. OK. All right, Brenda, thank you.
Yes, thank you very much. Bye.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Great to
speak to Brenda again. That is all the
time we have for today. If you didn't
make it into today's show, Fearnot,
there will be another opportunity.